Good Morning America co-hosts DJ Holmes
and Amy robach being investigated by ABC
following news of their romance multiple
sources tell ET it's been a great week
before this one to keep going and going
and going just enjoy it our sources say
ABC is conducting a review to see if the
two violated any company policies
specifically the company's morality
Clause keeping the romance alive in any
relationship well maybe it's a challenge
these days just a little bit sometimes
the investigation is also looking into
whether TJ's alleged relationships with
other ABC employees violated policies
about relationships between bosses and
subordinates because just days after
news of TJ and Amy's romance broke ET
learned he had an affair with the GMA
producer who left the show in 2017.
additionally two sources tell ET the TV
personality was also romantic with a
third woman who also no longer works at
the network as for when Amy and TJ
thought together another tip is to train
with friends you set the agenda you say
here's the reports
well a Second Source claims the co-host
didn't become romantically involved
until after August TJ isn't that your
favorite song
he always gets into the holiday spirit
why do I tell you things in confidence
and we're told that TJ's wife merely
phoebec got suspicious of his friendship
with Amy this summer while on vacation
in the Bahamas for his 45th birthday
quote they had already been through so
much trying to fix their marriage after
his affair with the former GMA producer
and then she saw a birthday card from
Amy that was way too familiar merely was
done after that the two journalists
separated from their spouses this summer
TJ from merrily and Amy from actor
Andrew Shu both have been married since
2010. I love that song Good afternoon
and welcome everybody to what you need
to know on this Monday Amy Robuck and TJ
Holmes have the day off yeah for the
time being Amy and TJ have been
temporarily removed from gma's third
hour as ABC execs figure out what their
next steps will be and while the
duration of Amy and TJ's time off air is
unclear A source tells E.T this is not a
disciplinary action it's just to let
things calm down we will spare you
America all right we want to head over
Ginger now meanwhile the pair is getting
support from their colleagues including
fellow anchor Don Lemon who's sending
love their way I know TJ I worked with
TJ at um at CNN so I have nothing but
love for him and I hope that he's okay I
don't know about their situation I'm not
privy enough but I just like to offer
people love and support and I hope that
they're okay and I hope I get to see
them in person again soon so I can give
them a hug
[Music]
thank you